-You've never heard me
swear before?
Well, aren't you in for a treat,
[bleep] you
and [bleep] your mother, too.
[ Elevator bell dings ]
♪♪
Yeah. That'll really get people
agreeing with your politics,
[bleep].
♪♪
[ Elevator bell dings ]
[ Indistinct conversations ]
♪♪
I'm here to see Julius Cain,
and this was in the elevator.
-Another one?
Tell security it was a man
in camouflage on 19th.
Could be Antifa,
could be Proud Boys.
-Thanks. Uh, your name, sir?
-Rahm Emanuel.
-Please take a seat.
-Sure.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Alan Cumming.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip From
"The Good Fight,"
final season.
-Yes.
-And you got to, you know,
come back
and play a character that
you played on "The Good Wife."
That must have been so nice.
-It was really lovely, actually.
I'm so glad I did it,
because when I did it,
I didn't know it was
going to be the last season.
-Yeah.
-And so I'm really glad
I've kind of gotten back.
And I was so nice to go back.
It was in the same studio,
it was a lot of the same people.
My daughter -- Sarah Steele,
who plays my daughter,
it was lovely to do stuff
with her again
and also to play --
and also to get to swear.
Because in "The Good Wife,"
that was on CBS,
so you weren't allowed to swear.
And of course, I sort of thought
inside my head sweary words
all the time
when I was playing him,
but I could never
actually say them.
So I got to say
the most awful things.
Yeah.
-Well, they sound --
they sound very lovely
coming from you.
-Yeah, I liked it.
-So nice job.
-You have a fascinating role
in a documentary coming out
called "My Old School."
-Oh, yes, yes.
It's out, actually. It's out.
It's really good.
It's called "My Old School,"
and it's -- I play --
like, I lipsync
the person who it's about
because they didn't want
to be seen in it.
So they did an audio interview,
and then so I lip sync them.
And what is bizarre
is that 25 years ago,
I was going to do a film,
a drama, a narrative film
and play that person.
-And this is the person --
This is a fairly famous story
about a 32-year-old
who went to...
-So he was -- there's a school
in Glasgow
called Bearsden Academy.
It's a sort of posh area
of Glasgow.
And he went there,
and then he became --
went to be a doctor and flunked.
And then he had to go.
He wanted to be a doctor again,
but there was a cutoff at age 34
to get back into medical school.
So he went back to the same
high school that he'd gone to
when he was 16
and did his exams again
in order to get
into medical school.
And the same teachers
were teaching him.
-And he was pretending to be 16?
-He was pretending to be 16.
He was pretending to be
this person from Canada
whose father -- mother
was an opera singer who died.
And it was, like,
this hilarious,
camp sort of back story.
And everyone believed it.
And he even went into
the school musical,
and it was "South Pacific,"
and he sang
"Younger Than Springtime."
[ Laughter ]
And nobody -- and nobody
caught him doing it.
I mean, all the kids sort of
called him 30-something
and stuff like that.
And it's a hilarious bit.
Go, "Are you my Dad?"
And they're all doing that,
but nobody actually realized.
And then when it did come out,
oh, my God, it was the huge --
And remember,
in sort of '93, '94.
it was this huge story
because in Scotland, like,
we don't like having the wool
pulled over our eyes.
But -- and we also
admire people who can.
So it was just we were all like,
"What?!"
And it was just
an immense story.
So it was kind of nice for me
as well to come
all those years later
to sort of play him.
It's not
an attractive role for me.
I don't know
if you've seen the poster.
-I haven't seen the poster
for it yet.
-It's not attractive.
-Okay.
-But, um...it was a great thing.
-Thank you for the warning.
-Yes. Just to --
You're also --
you're working with my queen.
This is my queen,
Miriam Margolyes.
-Oh, my God, Miriam. Yes.
-So this is -- she's one of the
funniest people in the world.
A wonderful actor.
-So hilarious.
So we this show in Britain --
it's on PBS as well, actually,
I think here.
It's called "Alan and --"
no, "Miriam and Alan,"
that's the billing.
"Miriam and Alan
Lost in Scotland" --
we did one last year,
and now we've done --
we're in the middle of doing
a second one --
"Miriam and Alan
Lost in Scotland and Beyond."
So next week, we meet up
again in California.
-Oh, wow.
-We go to California.
But this is us
at Loch Lomond last week,
where I officiated a wedding.
And she -- it was like a gay --
a gay couple
who were renewing their vows.
My second cousin, actually.
And I and I officiated that.
and Miriam did a reading.
She read
"The Owl and the Pussycat."
And I afterwards I said,
"I didn't --
Who'd have thunk at a gay
wedding would be so much pussy."
[ Laughter ]
But anyway, she's so hilarious,
and she's 81.
She's so foulmouthed,
and like a little girl
showing her knickers.
And I think where
it kind of become
this sort of kooky television
couple because I'm so --
"No, Miriam, stop it."
But then also
encouraging her to do things.
And she came to see "Burn"
when we were in Inverness,
and all the crew
were so excited to meet her.
You know, she's, like, a legend.
And she came into -- they all
came into my dressing room.
She was sitting there,
and I could tell she was like,
"Oh, I'm going to have fun
here."
And she just suddenly went,
"I've realized that I've come
to agree with Alan
about circumcision."
They're all like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
And she goes,
"Because I don't think people
should be circumcised.
He's quite right.
You have
a foreskin for a reason."
And I was like,
"Yes, thanks, Miriam.
Yes, thank you
for your support."
And then she goes, "But you
know, you've got to be
very aware of the smegma."
I'm like, "Alright!"
[ Laughter ]
And that's where go goes.
She starts in something,
and you think, "Oh, what is she
going on about?"
And then she made this gesture.
I went, "Okay, Miriam,
that's enough."
And she went, "No,
but some people store it."
Like that, and she made
this gesture like a shovel,
and I was like, "Do you mean,
like, shoveling smegma?
Is that what you're doing here?"
And she went,
"Yes, that's what they do."
And so that's
what you're dealing with.
-Just once again, that's who is
saying all that.
-This lady.
-That very sweet-looking lady
right there.
-Oh, and that's one of the
cleanest stories I can tell you.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, congratulations
on your show.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations on another
season --
well, just coming back
and doing "The Good Fight."
And it's so great to have you.
-Just being alive.
-Alan Cumming, just being alive.
"Burn" is playing now through
September 25th
at the Joyce Theater.
New episodes of the final season
of "The Good Fight"
are available Thursdays
on Paramount+.
We'll be right back with
Bobby Moynihan.